[Music]
this is exciting and interesting to me I
think I've uncovered a uh a new human
need there basic human needs like uh
love uh food shelter these are ones we
all have but I've uncovered one in
myself that uh that I call uh no one
tells me what to
do that's a real need that's a need for
me to do things that are like nobody
tell I'll give you an example uh I'm off
porn yeah
I I it's okay if you enjoy pornography
that's fine enjoy it I had a good run
with
it keep it up go go with
God but even if you love it I think we
can all agree on one thing when you're
when you're alone naked on your
bed except for your socks just just the
day socks still lingering on you the
only light hitting your face is the
light of your
laptop you're not at your best can we
agree that's not on the Highlight Reel
of your life when you're like what if I
was at this
orgy it's not a fine moment for you so I
stopped I'm off it and I've been talking
about being off porn sometimes as a
standup and one show I was talking about
it and somebody came up to me after the
show real sincere they were like hey hey
Pete that's what he sounded like hey hey
Peter I said yeah this part's not
important
yeah and he was like uh congratulations
I just want to say congratulations on
your
abstinence it's not easy brother I had
that beast on my back for a long time
but it's been two years two years it was
bad had to get my family
involved this is true it was interfering
with my work but two years clean so stay
strong brother stay
strong you know the first thing I did
that night when I got
home I bet you
do I fired up the laptop and reluctantly
jerked it to point I didn't even want to
I just did it be why cuz nobody tells me
what to do what are you talking about
I'm not in your weird little abson Club
scram nobody tells me when to feel good
I'm the king of the
castle I really feel like that's a
driving force behind so many things we
do in our lives like smoking everybody
knows you shouldn't smoke people I don't
smoke but people that smoke I completely
understand it's a pack of nobody tells
me what to do in your pocket eight bucks
that's a fair price for nobody tells me
each one is wrapped in paper like a
little Declaration of Independence
that you light on fire cuz nobody tells
you when to use fire you light it on
fire like a beacon from Two Towers just
hold it up in the air as if to say hey
yeah
everything I completely get it we all
get it even if you don't smoke Cold
Stone Creamery should just be called no
one tells you what to
do desserts listen to me now desserts
wrapped in inside other desserts just
like I'm the boss give it I got to have
it shove it in your face you're like
I'll take the cake wrapp it in the ice
cream put some insulin in while you're
at it and you know what I don't want it
to go I'm going to eat it here I want
you to watch me give myself type 2
diabetes the official disease of no one
tells you what to do in fact go grab my
cigarettes and my laptop I'm going for
the trifecta right here then I'm going
to do some day drinking and enter a hot
dog eating contest go for a lengthly
swim right after waiting 30 minutes
that's a myth nobody tells me what to
do it's a need it's a human
[Music]
need